- All right, y'all, we've
reached the end of the hour,
but we still have time
for one more great story.
This is "What I'm Liking".
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
It's no secret that I am
obsessed with Christmas music.
It's out there.
And I recently learned about
an awesome acapella group
that's gone super viral
for their holiday music.
In fact, their videos have amassed
more than 3.5 million
followers on TikTok alone.
Not only did they just put out
their very own EP called
"Like It's Christmas",
where they cover some holiday classics,
I'm also humbled to say they
did a really rad version
of my new Christmas song
"Christmas Isn't Canceled (Just You)".
It's amazing. Check this out.
♪ I'll be hanging every
light I find in this house ♪
♪ Playing Christmas music so loud ♪
♪ This year Christmas
won't be quite so blue ♪
♪ Pa-ra-pa-ra-pa-ra ♪
♪ And I'm gonna shout too
loud and dance in the snow ♪
♪ Drink too much just to let us go ♪
♪ Christmas won't be canceled, just you ♪
♪ Pow ♪
(audience cheering)
- I loved it.
It's like a different form of...
Can you imagine opening your
door to carolers singing that?
I just think it's funny.
We have The Trills on the line right now.
Let's say hi to Will, Aaron, Missy, Nick,
Kathryn, and Leroy!
(audience cheering)
- Hi!
- Hi.
- Literally, when I saw this,
I was like, "Oh, my God."
One, you sound amazing.
And two, I was like, "I need
you to go around America
to every tour just singing this song
like it's a happy carol."
(chuckles) I was like, "Awesome."
It's great to meet
y'all. You are so gifted.
So can you tell us more about your group?
- Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you too.
- So we started in
college, our freshman year.
We met at Towson University in Maryland
and very quickly, we discovered
that we all had something in common.
So by day three of college,
we had an acapella
group started in a dorm,
and then we auditioned in some
new friends and here we are.
- [Kelly] It's so cool.
- And it's wild to see it six years later
that the music continued to happen.
Obviously, we all come
from different backgrounds.
I played trumpet my whole life.
I actually lost the ability to
play trumpet around college.
So I was able to transition to acapella
right when Trills was starting
and having a musical outlet
for the last six years.
So it's really important to all of us.
- Yeah. Oh, my gosh.
It's so therapeutic, music.
So I love that you found that new outlet.
So Will, how does it
feel to attract millions
and billions of fans on TikTok?
- It's honestly surreal.
Like even beyond the numbers
and like the followers
that are like constantly growing,
it's just really cool to see
that there are people all over the world
who really care about our music,
who care about what we're doing,
even as people like following us
and messaging us personally,
and just like wanting to be excited
for all the projects that we're doing.
It's really awesome.
- Aw, that's so cool. Well,
thank you all so much.
It's literally like I
have a whole new like skit
I want to do with caroling,
with songs that might be inappropriate
to go house to house with.
I think it's funny.
But I'm liking your
poster right now, right?
(audience clapping)
(Trills members cheering)
All right. That's not all.
Our season long partner,
Pilot Pen makers of G2,
the go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson show
want to honor ultimate
overachievers just like y'all.
So in honor of you and
how you inspire others
to chase their dreams,
they are writing a check
for a thousand dollars to
Education Through Music.
(audience cheering)